é um prazer estar aqui todo mundo aqui
já tem um sonho tem um sonho sim
qualquer importância do sonho na vida
das pessoas né que o sonho significa
sonho na verdade é uma forma de
motivação
tenho peixoto não consegue enxergar o
futuro quem não tem sonho não conseguem
realmente ver que vale a pena continuar
fazendo alguma coisa que a gente vai
falar hoje é efetivamente o poder que um
sonho tem na vida especificamente de uma
criança portadora de uma doença grave
se o sonho tem importância para a gente
a adultos e adolescentes
imagina no na vida de uma criança e
realmente não enxerga o futuro né uma
criança que tem problema muitas vezes já
nasceu doente que muitas vezes não sabe
o que é brincar não sabe o que é uma
rotina fora de hospital caso a caso o
hospital
muitos adolescentes é que aquele plano b
pra escola né eu tenho muitas crianças
na meia hoje que sonham em ir pra escola
né sonham e estudar o que a gente vai
mostrar pra vocês hoje é exatamente um
pouco dessa história o que a gente faz
para tentar realizar o sonho dessas
crianças e transformar um pouquinho a
vida delas e eu quero começar a
apresentação com cinco nomes na tela de
personalidades personalidades distintas
de tempos distintos tores distintas
valores de chinos e perguntar pra vocês
rapidamente o que será que essas pessoas
têm em comum a cada um deles e eu
analisando rapidamente cada um deles a
história deles eles sobre duas coisas
que eles têm em comum
a primeira delas todos eles tinham um
sonho mas um sonho qualquer existe um
verdadeiro sonho uma obstinação em
vários casos não é uma coisa que
realmente mexia manta com eles e os
fazia acreditar
é possível só que eles também sabia que
nada disso seria possível sem ação
não adianta só ficar sonhando pensando
tinha que agir muito mais do que agir
ninguém realiza sonhos sozinho
a gente tem que engaja a gente tem que
trazer pessoas juntos então todos
aqueles tinha um sonho muito forte
engajaram muitas pessoas trabalharam
duro e com isso conseguiram realizar
processos transformadores processo de
transformação no mundo cada um sujeito
sem julgamento de valores mas
transformar e é isso também que o lixo
acredita o meia acredita que a
realização do verdadeiro sonho de uma
criança portadora de uma doença grave
ela cria uma experiência transformadora
não só na criança
mas nem todo mundo que participa da vida
dessa criança família e comunidade
vizinhos professores algumas vezes
enfermeiros e com isso a gente tenta
trazer para essa criança uma melhoria na
sua força emocional trazer mais
esperança mais fé mais força para que
ela continue acreditando que existe um
futuro e continue acreditando que vale a
pena lutar pela apresentar pra vocês
o guilherme que é uma criança que a
gente realizou só em 2012
guilherme el nino que ele adorava andar
de skate como muitos adolescentes
ele foi acometido de infância e com isso
ele equiparado à c net um sonho de ser
um profissional docente
eu sonho dele era p um guarda roupa da
ok pra quem não conhece ocre é uma marca
esportiva né
e muitos stay que esta série
a divisão vilela
- estou ao assunto pelo fogo
miele lula
lu ela se aldo empunhando o pai resolveu
de aiko tal venda
estou em bom só pedir fim de buscar ó
seu ano face ao pib com péssima sem
flash
sim ele leis em ai ai
op
deus hoje moro do euro
eu parei nos sempre lançar microbiana
conosco
o esgoto está na hora maico
já os cachorros
estão nela
aquelas coisas que falei com ninguém
meu carro está bom em bom tom
sou pedindo está dólar solano vencer
toque ponto pé se dá em frente
eu nem sei
ai ai ai
ó
deu-nos forró
o heu noé 0
o início que o merrill lynch acredita e
essa é a nossa missão dele que eu tenho
um trabalho mais precioso não é mais
deliciosos a realização em todo dia na
cruz
então a gente realizações de crianças de
3 a 18 anos que tem o seu futuro
ameaçado por uma doença grave em
crianças que realmente é requerem todo o
tratamento e corre risco de vida e
começou a make-a-wish exatamente com
esse garotinho o cris menino de 7 anos
de idade portador de leucemia am que já
tinha já na verdade quando o sonho foi
realizado já estava num estado bastante
avançada da sua doença ea mãe do
príncipe resolveu realizar seu sonho de
ser um policial e juntamente com toda a
comunidade nos estados unidos a unidade
fez ela realizou o sonho do filho e
vendo todo o benefício que a realização
desse sonho gerou crise ou seja
acompanhar de perto o cristo e depois o
sonho e vendo a força emocional de
aumentada e vendo como ele se sentia
feliz como ele comentava um sonho mesmo
após o falecimento do cris
além da resolveu que a causa não podia
acabar e que aquela experiência
maravilhosa que o filho dela tinha tido
ela tinha estender para outras crianças
também e aí na sua make a wish
instituição que hoje está presente em 47
países no mundo
já realizamos mais de 350 mil sonhos e
isso nos dá uma marca impressionante de
um sonho a cada 22 minutos ao redor do
mundo
no brasil nós estamos há cinco anos
já temos aí mais de 800 sonhos
realizados e mais de 150 fadas madrinhas
e gênios da lâmpada que é como a gente
chama os voluntários american idiot
muitas pessoas perguntam pra gente mas
funk que a criança sonho né
isso é assunto sonho com tudo
vocês podem imaginar e mais um pouquinho
né
mas internamente a gente divide os
sonhos em quatro categorias gente
desliga e sonhos de conhecer né
quando a criança tem um ídolo e esse
ídolo vai de papa cantor pop cantor de
funk
até amigas virtuais né às vezes se faz
na internet quer conhecer
então é um iglu alguém que eu quero
muito que vai fazer a diferença na minha
vida
temos também o sonho de ir quando a
criança é conhecer um lugar pra é o
lugar dos sonhos e isso varia não é só
disney né
em vários lugares que podem ser o lugar
dos sonhos de cada uma das crianças
temos também o sonho de ter esse mais
faltavam né
quando a criança é ter alguma coisa é
ter um eletrônico é um joguinho um
computador mas também muitos querem ter
um quarto decorado diferente do quarto
do hospital questão tão acostumado
temos finalmente o sonho de ser quando a
criança quer viver uma experiência né
desceram uma coisa que para ela é o
querido não é tão tem um bombeiro modelo
bailarina pintura tudo que se forma hoje
é que nós realizamos sonhos na meia hoje
basicamente quatro grandes etapas os
sonhos chegam até a make-a-wish a gente
não vai atrás de sonho a gente disse que
o processo de sonhar tem que começar no
sonhador e começar dentro do coração da
pessoa sonhou chega a nós fazer e quem
escreve né
quem escreve o sonho o méxico a primeira
se pólo em prata da criança os pais e no
caso de adolescentes às vezes a própria
criança inscreve o seu sonho também a
gente faz uma análise da elegibilidade
médica
ele tem uma doença que coloca em risco
está dentro da faixa etária que
mencionei pra vocês
a partir daí existe a entrega desse
projecto de sonho para as fadas e para
os gênios da lâmpada e eles vão através
de entrevistas com essa criança essa
família descobrir o verdadeiro sonho
aquele sonho que eu falei que motivou
aquelas quatro pessoas têm que descobrir
o verdadeiro sonho o sonho de sair do
estômago como eu digo nada nem do
coração é acreditar 1
aquele é o sonho certo é que vai fazer a
diferença e finalmente esse gênio de
fadas colocam a ação planejam vão atrás
de recursos vão entender como é que isso
vai transformar e finalmente fazer a
entrega do sonho aqui alguns apoiadores
da comunidade inédita então hospitais e
estações de apoio que acreditam que esse
lado esse lado de fortalecer o emocional
de fortalecer e da esperança para a
criança com a realização do sonho tem um
impacto direto no tratamento da criança
né porque se sente mais forte
consequentemente e responde melhor ao
tratamento e algumas pessoas nos
perguntam números mas realmente quantos
por cento nessas pessoas mais céticas
quanto por cento realmente é faz a
diferença não tem diferença na vida da
criança aos estados unidos mas que os
estados unidos foi uma pesquisa 2011 e
começo de 2012 e apresentou pra gente
apresentou para o mundo na verdade
alguns percentuais bastante elevados que
comprovam exatamente não só o poder do
sonho na criança né
melhoria da criança na força emocional e
de como isso melhor o seu quadro médico
mas comprova coisas como um
fortalecimento da união familiar
quem já teve filho doente ou presenciou
uma família com uma criança doente se
sabe exatamente que normalmente a
família se separa né fica um pedaço da
família a criança doente outro pedaço
com o resto da família
existe uma desestruturação familiar um
grande uma família pensando apenas na
doença e na cura e quando a gente leva
um sonho e faz todo mundo participar
dessa família sempre unida em prol de
uma causa linda que a realização do
sonho daquela criança
elas também aí um grande expressivo
percentual de pessoas voluntárias e
parceiros que se sentem extremamente
motivados e com vontade de se doar mais
de dar mais e de fazer nesse mundo
melhor
então eu convido a todos vocês que a
gente não apenas o inep porque sonhos em
ação é só uma ilusão né
vamos juntos com compromissos
comprometimento de cada um de nós
e mais o vídeo em bagé lido muitas
pessoas transformar realmente cada
momento e cada vida em algo muito
especial
eu é docinho festa da fé e que tem tudo
em ordem estar em guerra
rio é pouquinho esse efeito tem minha
calça e mandou quem envenenou ribéry
espiados quem não antes em seguir tendo
e não tinha 10 estoque o que me diz
karen
ai ai ai e gestão
ae
então
esse choro é campeão
canindé
em um rápido rio com esse sistema não é
96 pelo menino
acho que o futebol é quem tanto vem
milhões mo paulo ronan detido
l'aquila lingle errar lugão
ele descarta ganhar
tá
chan destacou
ele ganhou
esses papéis
eu
é legal
nenhum carro